this is places for scenic  action lucy  i'm home  [Music]  why is this coming out now  lucille ball's a threat to the american  way of life  does the fbi have any case against lucy  i need you to help me save my marriage  how many times i gotta explain where i  was and what i was doing you gotta  explain are you being funny i'm lucille  ball when i'm being funny you'll know  this is getting out of hand have you  been cheating on me the story's made up  if they fool me if they push you  we're done  sorry  i got lost for a second  [Music]  you're my hero  care about what works  i care about what's funny  i care about you  oh you're scaring the [ __ ] i was just  gonna say  good show good show good show  [Music]  we've been through worse than this  we have  no  [Music]  [Music]  you